costumes are much more than just the
clothes actors wear on screen they've
been called the skin of the character an
integral part of defining the characters
we play this award recognizes the style
makers colorist and fabricators of that
wonderful skin and their abundant
imaginations came fairytale fashions
post-apocalyptic creations and precise
historical reconstructions all of them
masterpieces so here are the nominees
for achievement in costume design
Cinderella costume design by sandy power
the Danish girl costume design by Paco
Delgado Carol costume design by Sandy
Powell
the revenant costume design by
Jacqueline West Mad Max fury road
costume design by Jenny Beavan and the
Oscar goes to Jenny Beavan
this is the second Oscar in 10th
nomination for Jenny Beavan
who took home her first Oscar in this
category for a room with a view
what another lovely day very quickly if
Ian Smith are amazing executive producer
from Scotland hadn't sent me a text
saying what she doing at the moment and
then got me on a plane out to meet
George Miller and Doug Mitchell aye
I wouldn't obviously be standing here it
was a year of our lives in the Namibian
desert we had the most amazing crew I
hope that some I'd heard they were on
ticker-tape I thought they were the
names were going on the screen but
honestly if anybody wants to know more
about any of them just get in touch with
me through my wonderful agents way in
fitmin from William Morris and Sue
Latimer from Arg but it was an
incredible experience but I just want to
say one quite serious thing and I've
been thinking about this a lot but
actually it could be horribly prophetic
Mad Max if we're not kinder to each
other and if we don't stop polluting our
atmosphere so you know it could happen